so uh own it down the purpose of it was  supposed to be okay bypass mainstream  media bypass the gatekeepers that's why  twitter developed speak directly with  your fans that's the value that twitter  would bring that's the currency so when  you look at the series of answers from  jack dorsey where he's unable to  articulate  unable to articulate his point of view  on the sole value the currency that  twitter provides that's when you see the  stock take a nosedive not to mention the  inconsistency so tim poole brought up  the idea of free speech here's jack  dorsey articulating his thoughts in a  crystal clear manner in terms of  what we're trying to drive is  opportunity for every single person to  be able to  speak freely on the platform and that's  that's absolutely not true  you you would know a lot a lot hate  speech so free speech is not on your  platform i said